[Musique]
bonjour et merci de nous rejoindre pour
une nouvelle saison a dû s est 8 ce
loisir sur tv et 78 chaque jeudi nous
allons vous donner le plus d'idées
possible pour occuper vos week-ends
votre temps libre dans les yvelines le
sommaire pour aujourd'hui elancourt
lance la deuxième saison de sa
commanderie est le samedi 14 septembre
arts visuels ateliers des sciences po
résidence nous parlerons du programme
avec carmelo brié vice-présidente en
charge de la culture à saint quentin en
yvelines se remettre au sport tout en
douceur cela peut peut-être faire partie
de vos résolutions pour cette année nous
vous ferons tout à l'heure découvrir le
stretching postural proposé notamment
par une association de plaisir une
méthode à base d'étirements et de
contraction musculaire associée à des
respirations spécifiques et puis à
l'agenda complet de vos sorties pour ce
week end découverte du street art à
conflans sainte honorine fête du vélo à
montigny le bretonneux ou encore brame
du cerf à rambouillet
[Musique]
pour débuter quelques rendez vous à
noter dans vos agendas samedi 14h30
embarqué à chatou pour une balade sur la
scène en compagnie d'un guide
conférencier à l'occasion du centenaire
de la disparition de renoir est le
peintre impressionniste a réalisé une
trentaine de toiles dans cette commune
et aux alentours
autre ambiance un peu plus tôt dans la
journée à rambouillet la ville poursuit
son voyage dans les sixties avec un
madison géant au centre ville organisé
par les commerçants l'opération
rambouillet y ait débuté la semaine
dernière se poursuit jusqu'à la fin du
mois il y aura aussi des expositions des
défilés et des spectacles et puis si aux
années 60 vous préférez les années 2007
à conflans sainte honorine qu'il faudra
vous rendre samedi tout au long de
l'après-midi la mjc les terrasses va
célébrer le street art
une trentaine d'artistes propose des
démonstrations des ateliers graff
notamment et le soir place aux concerts
bonjour armelle ouvriers et bienvenue
sur ce plateau vous êtes élu à
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines en charge de la culture ce
samedi lé long cours se déroulent le
lancement de la deuxième saison de la
commanderie journée qui sera festive qui
va débuter à partir de 17h et de
nombreux rendez-vous pour brosser comme
ça un petit peu un panorama on va aller
de l'expérience scientifique à la poésie
à la photographie en fait vous avez dit
au départ elle encourt lance sa saison à
la commanderie non c'est 5 en taquinant
sa saison est là à la commanderie et
j'insiste là dessus parce qu en fait
justement à la commanderie ce que l'on
veut faire c'est c'est pas de la culture
classique mais c'est quelque chose qui
est à l'image de saint quentin et on y
trouve effectivement de la danse des
arts visuels des sciences et j'ai oublié
les itinéraires une politique donc pour
justement le samedi prochain donc le 14
de 17h à minuit on va va montrer ce que
tout ce qui est capable tout ce qui se
passera à la commanderie est en fait à
la commanderie après 7
cette période de lancement donc je lui
parlais juste après je veux dire il y
aura tous les week-ends quelque chose
qui les danses dans cet esprit dans cet
esprit là donc samedi on va commencer à
17 heures on finit à minuit à minuit à
paris à partir de 22 heures jusqu'à
minuit c'est un dj chacun pourra danser
mais l'on va retrouver de 17h à 22h tous
que tout ce que le à 51 peut proposer à
la commanderie
il y aura un grand atelier d'expérience
et acoustique de 17h à 20h ça s'est
animée par les scientifiques de
l'université paris ii su plus + un
musicien professionnel et ont fait
danser des films de savon à l'aide
d'ondés sonores entre autres et bien
qu'elle cette volonté d'associer les
arts la science sur un seul et même
endroit dorénavant c'est la vie n
et puis à partir de 17h où on aura aussi
des gesticulations textuel alors avec
microphone mégaphone bigophone
ça sera puis aussi sur des dépôts m
en fait et puis de 17 heures à 22 heures
il y aura les photographes free de dan
ramène qui fait une série d'image autour
de la nature et de la transcendance
mais ça va aussi avec la mission danse
est en fait d'un g n
c'est un artiste photographe qui est en
résidence à la commanderie et en même
temps il ya eu un échange avec le
mexique
donc il y aura aussi dans ce premier
trimestre à la commanderie quelqu'un du
mexique qui viendra faire une exposition
et là aussi c'est sur la nouvelle
photographie et puis à 18 heures il y
aura des parcours dansé il ya des pièces
chorégraphiques de christian et françois
ben aïm on va en voir des images parce
qu'elle est là des petits teasers qui
ont été réalisés justement par
l'agglomération que nous avons récupéré
on va vous les montrer voilà ces
artistes qui vont se produire ce sera au
sein de la chapelle
au-delà de cette journée de lancement
pour saint quentin en yvelines
là l'idée c'est de faire vivre ce site
ce lieu aussi d'y attirer aujourd'hui
les visiteurs de tous saint quentin en
yvelines dans un cadre historique
le but est d attirer des visiteurs de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et des
visiteurs à l'extérieur de saint quentin
en yvelines ça quand on devine c'est une
réussite et c'est une réussite dans tous
les domaines et donc en particulier
aussi dans la culture justement on va
avec la nouvelle je peux pas appeler ça
la nouvelle culture mais la culture
adaptés au mode de vie des
et des habitants on est plus il n'y a
pas de la danse d'un côté puis la danse
classique quand c'est en fait avec les
nouvelles méthodes et puis en fait vous
voyez que le numérique que c'est un peu
ça traduit par tous et c'est ce à quoi
l'on veut que l'on me développer
lancement pour la commanderie le 14 le
programme est bien évidemment détaillé
sur le site internet de l'agglomération
on aura l'occasion de parler du
programme de la commanderie au cours des
prochains numéros du 7-8 loisirs parce
qu'il est très riche
on peut d'ores et déjà annoncer que pour
les journées du patrimoine ya des
manifestations qui sont prévues week-end
des 21 et 22 septembre et puis il y à
une nuit blanche aussi lé 5 octobre un
village des sciences aussi en octobre
l'élu 10 days en novembre voilà
programme est déjà riche pour le premier
trimestre et en même temps je voudrais
aussi à appuyer sur le fait que pendant
les vacances scolaires
on aura c'est les vacances ou en fait
justement il y aura des ateliers ça peut
accueillir jusqu'à 40 enfants qui vont à
la fois faire de la danse c'est un
parcours plus rudes issing
pluridisciplinaire et ils auront de la
danse de la poésie guns 'n de
l'informatique est un plasticien
merci beaucoup mais l'ouvrier d'être
venu nous parler déjà de ce lancement
pour la commanderie programmation
culturelle à saint quentin en yvelines
ça sera basé à elancourt sur le site de
la commanderie 14 septembre à partir de
17 heures l'entrée est libre
merci encore à vous le 7 8 loisirs qui
se poursuit à présent avec un point sur
les sorties ciné comme chaque semaine
aujourd'hui c'est le directeur du ciné
c'est elle encore qui nous reçoit dans
sa salle
[Musique]
alors dans les salles cette semaine et
notamment aussi 17 le très très beau
film d'animation que j'ai eu la chance
de voir à cannes de zabou breitman et je
ne veux pas écorché son nom
a gobé mais vd qui s'appelle les
hirondelles de kaboul
donc c'est une adaptation d'un roman de
yasmina khadra et ça nous plonge en 1998
à kaboul ville qui vient d'être soi
disant libérer du joug russe par les
talibans et où on assiste évidemment à
une espèce de terreur qu'ils installent
des exécutions sommaires etc etc et on
va suivre l'histoire de deux personnages
principaux deux jeunes afghans qui
s'appelle mohsen et zune et qui sont
plein d'utopie plein de rêves et qui
cherchent à vivre leur amour
tranquillement fait tranquillement le
plus tranquillement possible dans kaboul
jusqu'au jour où bruxelles va commettre
l'irréparable je ne vous en dis pas plus
donc c'est à découvrir nos salles c'est
un très très beau film d'animation qui
fait penser célestine puisque et léa à
travailler sur le fond ernest et
célestine
donc c'est très très fluide c'est très
très beau très très belle musique aussi
donc vraiment n'hésitez pas à court et
et ne soyez pas rebutés par le fait que
ce soit un film d'animation est aussi
avoir dans nos salles deux mois le la
dernière livraison de cédric klapisch
très réussi
[Musique]
nous poursuivons notre tour d'horizon
des manifestations pour le week-end à
venir dans le 7-8 loisirs et maintenant
depuis 160 ans croissy-sur-seine célèbre
la carotte samedi et dimanche des
ateliers des animations et même un
spectacle pyrotechnique qui vont se
dérouler dans le parc chanot riez on
écoute le maire de la ville nous en dire
un petit peu plus sur cette tradition
c'est l'histoire de la ville puisque
croatie goût départ c'est un certain
nombre de maraîchers avec eux deux
écumant play pratiques qui sont la
carotte mais pas n'importe quel carottes
la carotte à bout rond et puis les
salades et les laver et partent
clairement dans les salades et d'espèces
de salah qui s'appelle la blonde
paresseuse tous les terrains des
maraîchers ont été vendus il nous reste
juste un maraîcher qui fait ça à titre
bénévole dans un grand jardin qui lui
reste il y en a plus aucun maraîchers
non c'est simplement la fête de rentrée
qui sous de la totalité de la communauté
croise yonne on a des expositions
puisque c'est aussi la fête de renoir
nous fait que l'on retrouve dans toute
la vallée des impressionnistes
d'immenses ya là la fête de la carotte
par e-mail
c'est à dire que vous avez les
associations en tient un stand sur tout
le château avec aussi un certain nombre
d'animations pour les enfants animations
gratuites je précise
un rendez vous nature également ce week
end à rambouillet l'espace rambouillet
qui vous accueillent pour écouter le
brame du cerf l'automne approche la
période d'accouplement débute le hénaff
vous livre les clés pour comprendre ce
rituel au coeur de la forêt
[Musique]
on passe aux sports la wild west réalise
pardon de thoiry et dimanche trois
courses nature sont annoncés au sein du
parc zoologique parcours 100 % nature
pour observer en toute sécurité bien
évidemment les animaux et puis plus
traditionnels la fête du vélo débute ce
vendredi 13 septembre à montigny le
bretonneux jusqu'au dimanche soir 1600
personnes sont attendues pour des raids
vtt à des parcours cyclo touristique et
débutants et familles sont les
bienvenues si vous trouvez que les
bienfaits à des vacances sont oublier le
stress vous envahit déjà voici à présent
une discipline qui peut vous permettre
de recharger les batteries sans brusquer
votre organisme le stretching postural
c'est son nom accueille de plus en plus
d'adeptes nous avons assisté à une
séance du côté de plaisir ce matin pour
le groupe de retraités ces séances de
stretching postural les tapis en place
ils vont pouvoir adopter des postures
pour étayer leurs muscles profonds et
posturaux notamment ceux du dos on met
en place les positions comme si vous
mettiez des couches les unes après les
autres
toujours en respect de nos chaînes
musculaires en respect de nos
articulations
donc petit à petit on monte en puissance
atteint d'une maladie génétique qui
bloque les articulations
s'ils viennent bien depuis quelques
temps au cours de stretching
sur les conseils de son kinésithérapeute
c'est pas évident évident mais moi je
trouve que c'est enfin moi
personnellement je sais que ça me fait
du bien même si il y en a certains
posture je souffre un peu
c'est là un effort intense et bref qui
s'adapte à tous les âges pour préparer
une compétition de sport pour se
détendre pour soigner des maladies comme
dominique qui souffrent d'arthrose
mais qui vient essentiellement pour son
bien-être physique et morale
visuellement c'est vrai que c'est
difficile de se rendre compte de ce que
l'on peut ressentir de par la posture
parfois on a déjà un certain travail
ensuite la mobilisation la durée qui est
quand même relativement courte on est
soutenu aussi par la petite respiration
qui est très spécifique au stretching
postural un sport qui sert à évacuer les
tensions et retrouver une harmonie
corporels pour appréhender l'année tout
en douceur c'est la fin de ce set 8
loisirs émission retrouvez dès à présent
replay sur notre site internet et
l'application mobile rendez vous jeudi
prochain 18h30 sur tv soixante dix huit
pour de nouvelles idées sorties
[Musique]
oh